there's an article that Google has out
of what content is not suitable for ads
or will result in limited or no ads
when it comes to monetization so there's
two things that could happen if you have
questionable content in your videos
number one ads are just disallowed
completely or number two they're limited
or no ads which typically tanks yours
you might make it instead of making 10
or 20 grand a video for big creators
they'll make two grand significantly
throttled amount of money so here are
some of the main topics that are not
Advertiser friendly and this is not even
an exhaustive list but it's quite a bit
of things so these things can drive down
how much money you earn from YouTube
inappropriate language violence adult
content shocking content harmful or
dangerous acts hateful or derogatory
content recreational drugs and drug
related content Firearms related content
controversial issues sensitive events
incendiary or demeaning content tobacco
related content and adult themes in
family content so the summary there is
PG PG-13 family friendly content is
going to have the greatest opportunity
for the most ads this is a whole
conversation in and of itself because
some creators who have more adult themed
content want they say well there's a lot
of brands or businesses that would want
to reach our audience but my rebuttal to
that would be yeah and that's why you
can do brand deals and that's why you
can do your own thing and you can build
your own platforms other places or you
could have you build an email list and
you can sell email drops to sponsors but
I empathize I mean I see the frustration
is sometimes people sometimes these
things are unclear or sometimes you
don't know why your video has limited or
no ads but nevertheless if you want the
safest bet of not having limited ads on
your YouTube videos than being
thoughtful of those types of keeping
inappropriate language and violence and
harmful content out of your videos an
important factor for just avoiding any
of that drama and any of that trauma